[موسيقى]
منذ لحظه ولاده هلال شهر رمضان والقمر
يسير خلف الشمس متجها من جهه الشرق الى
جهه الغرب محاولا بكل جديه ان يدرك الشمس
وسيدركها في صباح يوم الخميس 20 ابريل في
تمام الساعه 7:00 و 12 دقيقه وحينئذ يولد
الهلال ولاده مشاهده على استراليا
وماليزيا وسنغافوره مدغشقر اللي هي كسوف
الشمس وولاده خفيه غير مشاهده على بقيه
بلدان العالم وفي مساء ذلك اليوم اللي هو
يوم الخميس سيكون للقمر مكسون قرابه النص
ساعه وعلى هذا الاساس فان رمضان لهذه
السنه سينتهي في يوم بدا فيه فقد بدا يوم
الخميس وسينتهي يوم الخميس والجمعه اول
ايام العيد سعيد على جل البلدان العربيه
والاسلاميه وكل عام وانتم بخير اهنئ
بالعيد من وجه هو العيد لولا حالي طالعا
وادعو الى الله سبحانه بشمل يكون لنا
جامعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والهلال لا يشاهد الا اذا تحققت اركانه
وتوافرت شروطه واهمها ان يولد الهلال قبل
مغيب الشمس وان يكون للهلال بعد مغيب
الشمس والهلال هلالين هلال للخاصه لا
يشاهده الا حديد البصر وهو التصوير وهذا
يكون يوم الخميس ليله الجمعه وهلال للعامه
يشاهده عامه الناس وهذا يكون يوم الجمعه
ليله السبت سنون تعاد ودهر يعيد لها امرك
ما في الليالي جديد اضاء لادم هذا الهلال
فكيف تقول الهلال الوليد
[موسيقى]